في مشهد مؤثر تصدر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي يظهر رجل معتمر يحمل فيه والدته
للطواف بها امام الكعبه فيما حصل الفيديو
على ارشادات واسعه ولكن في المقابل انتقد
البعض ما قام به الرجل اتجاهها والدته
[موسيقى]
صغيره الله يتقبل منا منهم يا رب
في حادثه غريبه لا تتكرر كثيرا في عالم
المستديره ترا حكم المباراه سام بريك في
الخروج على نقاله لاصابه في راسه بعد
ارتطام الكره الكره براسه في مباراه
الدوري الانجليزي وحسب تقرير صحفيه شعر
الحكم بالدوار مع طره لمغادره الملعب
محمول على نقاله وسط تصفيق الجمهور في
الملعب
[تصفيق]
وتداول ايضا رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو لاكبر لاكبر المخلوق على الارض
وهو الحوت الازرق الذي يصل وزنه لسانه فقط
الى اربعه اطنان اي ما يعادل وزنه فيلا
افريقي بالغ